hooked up with a girl and found out she
was married
whoa no
no i've had i've had that's happened to
guys i've had on my show before
oh they found out like she had a whole
like family
that's so like me
um how do i put this um
yeah yeah but like
i already knew
you just didn't care
i didn't care because dave service no
life like
don't you think i'm doing you a favor as
a man like let's say he was a man right
and
you have a girlfriend that's not even
saying your wife and then another guy
has sex with your girlfriend or whatever
i did you a favor
right
right like who a favorite the guy
because it's like because it's like bro
you expose this girl did you tell him
no well then how did you do him a favor
i don't know
but at the same time
well
uh that's too much information um
like you do have a favor if you told him
but if he doesn't find out then how did
you do him a favor [ __ ] i don't know
about that bro
[Music]
the reason why i don't feel bad i am
guilty 100 but the reason why i don't
feel bad is because it's like
bro
like you are going to do this anyway
or the guy down the street
or your neighbor
it was going to happen because you did
it someone said we in australia now we
in london bro
actually i got okay so i have a couple
so have you heard have you guys watched
manosphere content
no um yeah i don't even know okay so i'm
gonna give you so many shout outs
um it's basically like studying women
and sometimes i listen to like the
things they say to watch out for
and i think they're kind of funny but i
want to see if you guys think there's
any truth to these
tattoos they say girl with tattoos it's
like
like what did they say if a girl has
tattoos each tattoo is like 10 dicks
she's
i don't agree with that tattoos
they say hoop earrings when you say
tattoos though girls are like big hoop
earrings they're like no i get the
tattoos
but when you say tattoos
yeah like do you just mean like any
tattoos because there's certain girls
with tattoos
you know what i'm saying yeah so like
but not necessarily she's had sex with
this and that guy but just like hmm like
other guys must be looking at her the
same way
because yeah um i don't know they just
say they just they really do not like
tattoos in the sector of youtube i agree
with what he said like i love to like
tats are great it's art exactly and
sometimes you see girls and they just
have
some nice tattoos
yeah like enhancers are like god like
good tats can take someone like i'm
sorry to use the rating system that
could make turn a seven to a nine yes
yes yes yes
yes yes yes
speak for yourself i love some tests
like but like
i think the the type of tats like you
said like if she got something like on
on her like tailbone that says daddy's
little
you know i'm saying like i'm gonna know
right there like nah i'm not about it
but you know what i'm saying like
like i said you know what ty's nice you
know you know you know when the girls
got like um
like she got like chinese writing down
her spine like all the way down oh she
got like a dragon on her back like that
those tails like something's intricate
like yeah
yeah yeah those types
yeah no i mean
the thing about the manosphere like
it's such a
i don't know you see a lot of guys like
it's such a big
it draws a lot of attention and so
all these guys are popping up claiming
to be alphas and they have the key to
like you know what they call like red
pill information for guys like how to
wake up and take your manhood back but
it's like you know what i'm saying like
what's their credibility it's just some
guys just be talking [ __ ] well
because in my opinion i think they they
had to have struggled with women because
why else would they get into it
you have to fight like you have to find
the content somehow yeah like some
people you can tell they struggle with
women and they can they can take the
struggle take the crucial information
that they need yeah and give out
knowledge and then there's guys who
take the struggles with women and just
take all the painful stuff and then just
project out on the guys and pretty much
just say f all women i think those are
typically the guys that like women don't
want
so they just get mad because
girls will never want to give them the
time of day yeah you know
it's a weird field it's a weird sector
of youtube i i was when i tell people
what i do i'm like i don't even know how
to describe it like
like this sector of youtube you know do
you know about the stages of women's
like life they go through
do you know about the epiphany phase
the epiphany oh this is fun okay okay
okay okay i love explaining red pill
topics to people that have never heard
of it
so they'll say like a girl based on her
age um is gonna look for like different
things
so a girl from
between like 18 say to 26
is gonna look for like the fun guy
they're like god have a good time with
whatever but like 27 it depends on the
girl but like 27 28 to 35 they're more
like looking for the calm like the beta
guys like the providers yeah do you have
you found that to be true
like does that does that replicate what
you've seen in the real world or does
that just sound like nonsense
yeah the married woman like you spoke
that happened right
so like
that has to be [ __ ] because
yeah it has to be [ __ ] it has to be
[ __ ] nah nah it's not i'm sure no
but but do you know how they they
justify that
okay so they call it they call it
genuine like desire
no it's really cringey i know these
topics are really cringey but i actually
agree as a girl then weakness bro
it's called weakness bro
no no no i i actually i kind of agree
with this topic as a girl like because
because there's certain like
uh like
there's certain guys where you have more
of like
you're like more attracted to than
others so basically they'll say like
the the beta guy the provider guy
they'll marry but they really don't want
him they just want someone to have a
family with yeah because i've definitely
seen girls
yeah but because i've definitely seen
girls where they're like dating a guy
but they like want their ex boyfriend
like i see that all the time
yeah
no and among like normal girls i've i've
i don't get that like one time there's a
girl i tell the story i don't get it
either there's another person there
there is a girl i knew in college okay
and she she dated this guy for like a
month
i didn't really get it cause he was like
five seven i'm like you cannot be
tripping over a guy that's five seven i
did not get it and
and he um was that like her toxic her
toxic ex guy that she was still tripping
over though yeah i don't know they did
it for like a month it wasn't like i
don't know i mean i got nothing to do
with it i mean you probably had swag or
something like he i don't know he was a
loser
i didn't get it i did not get it but but
she ends up like
they break up whatever he breaks up with
her she dates a new guy he buys her a
house okay
she yeah he buys her a house she he's
moving her into the house
how quick this is years later
this is this is like freshman year she
met the first guy okay okay and she kind
of like hook up with him on and off and
this man was like
wilden like yeah and anyway so it was
her like junior maybe senior year she
starts dating a new guy yeah
senior
either is either senior year the year
after senior year
she hooked up with the freshman year guy
in a party like at a party in the
bathroom
like and i and i saw her go in when you
say hooked up like they [ __ ] about it
i don't know what else they were doing
in there that long
i had to distinguish because like when
i'm from when they say hook up they just
mean like kids no no no no no but but
but then then her the guy that got her
the house came later
to the same party
and i'm telling you this was the most
normal girl you would not guess it like
she oh my god i was shook
no female surprises me anymore do you
want that old thing back
but that's that's what i think of when i
think of like alpha and beta is i think
like she had the genuine desire for like
the first guy and the second guy like
she was like the safe option
and i think she's still with him to this
day i hope they're doing good but
[Music]
i mean i don't even see it as like yeah
i think it's deeper than the alpha beta
thing because like i hate those words
yeah it's still like it's just like it's
like it's so black and white like oh
you're either alpha beta bro you know
what i'm saying like well it could be a
thing like he emotionally manipulated
her for a long time when she was like
vulnerable
and then part of her still like well i
don't think it's alpha or beta i think
it's like it's not about if the guy is
alpha beta it's how does a girl see him
yeah so it's not it's not like is the
guy alpha and every because you're
always going to find a guy that's more
out like there's always going to be
someone but it's more like like the girl
has to see you as like the best she can
do
and if she sees someone else is the best
she could do she's always gonna want the
other guy
ah
wait i don't understand that that don't
make no sense but kyra look at i mean
this is just that's interesting this is
red pill ideas
because that's that's
no because
no no no because the reason i got i kind
of got into red pill was um
like it was they called an alpha widow
and that's like the concept that i'm
explaining right now okay was i felt
like in college i was like i feel like
every girl in my friend group there's
like one guy they just can't get over
and and like that girl that's what i
think of when i think of an alpha widow
was that was that her the person she
lost her virginity to as well because
that that still couldn't be that's what
she hooked up to
no no he's talking about the first one
because because she she slept with her
freshman year like when she was yeah
that's like an emotional connection so
yeah the guy that i lost my virginity to
made me not have sex for two years i was
like yeah yeah that's what you mean
why because i was sad
wait
explain
why
because i was like
this is kind of embarrassing um no
because
i don't know i was just like obsessed
and so
like i like moved cities and i didn't i
didn't want to like do it anymore
because i was like
they're just like i didn't want to get
hurt again but
wait we moved cities would you be away
from him yeah because i was like yeah
that's real though that's mad like what
the [ __ ] did he do
he made you move
to a whole city
yeah i swear i moved from chicago to it
wasn't that far it was like two hours
but far enough
it's like chicago to milwaukee
why
why i'm asking so many questions um
no i mean
i don't know i like
what do they call it like one idis when
you think it's like there's only one guy
it'll never be anyone like i don't know
it wasn't it was it was just like i
really didn't have like i'd only had sex
with him so it was like
yeah and that i yeah
he was like when i need to i go to him
is that where he was
like that's that's what i mean i wanted
to date him like because i got him a job
actually
oh boy you are one
yeah i'm not even one of them because i
think all girls are
like like you said like
if you lose your virginity to a boy
you're down to do anything for that man
no
yeah i know i was i i definitely like
got him
i like pretty good job actually because
my parents know a lot of people so like
it's like pretty easy if i want to like
set someone up with something that's
what you're telling me about before
what you told me i don't know you told
me
you gave a guy a job you gotta get a job
which time